hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV today
we're talking to Patrick Byrne a PhD and
the CEO of overstock.com now let's talk
about overstock.com describe its
business and why should people shop
there the businesses we're basically an
outlet store on the internet heavy deep
therein the more in the edge of retail
there are these folks that you and they
usually never meet you and I and they're
sort of bada-bing but above mine knows a
guy who knows a guy got this deal going
at say Co he's got something a Polaroid
you know that world well we're we sort
of have our feet in that world we bring
it on to the Internet and then we wrap
it up in great customer service so it's
the reason to shop there as you'll save
a lot of money one of the reasons we're
talking to you in DC is that you're in
here too you're talking to people about
the Delahunt Enzi bill which is a
bipartisan attempt Democrat and
Republican to get Internet and catalog
vendors to collect sales taxes for
remote purchases an estimated thirty
billion dollars goes uncollected each
year what what's wrong with you
collecting sales tax
why shouldn't online retailers have to
play by the same rules as bricks and
mortar operations well first of all back
in the early 90s there was a Supreme
Court decision quill versus North Dakota
that said it's too onerous there's 7,000
it's two owners for catalog company to
have to collect taxes and we're like a
you know internet companies and kalalau
companies there's 7,000 taxing
jurisdictions in the u.s. in one
jurisdiction cotton candy is food and
another it's you know entertainment or
it's candy different tax rates how can
we possibly know that tax rates and
7,000 jurisdictions that's reason number
one now they say well we can create
databases and overcome that they haven't
done that yet even if they do we put a
lot lesser load on a local
infrastructure and then it does to build
a target when you have a target there
you've got employees you've got to have
roads you have schools - for the
employees children to go to and such we
don't impose nearly that load so it
isn't fair those Jeff
let's talk about one of your other
issues which is short selling short
selling is a practice in which investors
borrow stock and then resell it later
hopefully at a loss so that they pocket
a difference between what it was lent
for and what they pay it back for are
you against short selling in principle
not in the least
short selling is fine so it sounds that
injects information into the marketplace
it's a useful activity how what
information does short selling inject
into the marketplace well it injects
information when people are that think a
stock is going to go down when they
think it's overvalued they're they're
accepting a cost the cost of borrowing
the shares and by doing that as they
sell it does put their opinion into the
marketplace what I have a beef against
is naked short-selling I feeling I'm out
there campaigning against sexual
harassment and people come back and say
oh no no sex is good sex is fine well
sexual harassment isn't a type of sex a
sea lion is not a type of lion naked
short-selling is not really a kind of
shorts okay now a naked short-selling
people are talking about selling shares
that they don't even own yet or have
borrow correct why is that worse than
regular shorts well because they have
avoided the cost of actually borrowing
stock the information they're injecting
is literally value less what you are a
libertarian you're hardcore capitalist
and yet you're also a an advocate of
good regulation how do we what is good
regulation of financial markets and what
is simply self-interested regulation of
financial markets well what we have now
is self regulated in regulation a
self-interested regulation the The Wall
Street has captured the regulatory body
good regulation and when it comes to the
clearing and settlement system it's
simply we should have a settlement
system that actually settles stock would
be better than a settlement system that
allows there to be this much slop I know
it seems confusing because people say
well you're a libertarian you're against
regulation you know my understanding of
libertarianism includes that there's a
role for government and prevent
force and fraud well force and fraud can
exist especially in the financial
marketplace because it's the essence of
a financial company being the business
of saying all take your money now and
I'll give you something later if you're
if your car had subscrive y'all so it's
a bit of financial industry in general
is very right for fraudsters do you
think the the economic crisis that were
in or the financial situation we're in
is it a result of lack of regulation or
deregulation or is it bad regular bad
regular it's two things it's bad
regulation and it's captured regulators
and we have extensive regulatory capture
in DC as I've been discovering for four
years so the whole argument about we
need more regulation seems to me
misguided I'm reminded Joseph Schumpeter
said that capitalism stands before the
jury of intellectuals and they over the
jury already has the guilty verdict in
their pocket they're just waiting to
hear the indictment read so we it isn't
that we need more regulation we need
better regulation and we need to stop
regulatory capture are you selling
Schumpeter at overstock.com I suspect
there's a warehouse of his works yeah
and you could get at a deal right he
goes way too unread you're a huge
advocate of school choice talk a little
bit about the Milton and Rose Friedman
foundation as well as your efforts to
expand school choice well I'm I'm I was
extremely blessed to meet Milton and
Rose and some years before his death and
I had just been become gradually a big
advocate of school choice I think that a
lot of issues I see the left and the
right fight about really urges
downstream effects of terrible education
system Milton or and a rare example of
bad judgment from Milton he well I
succeeded him as as co-chair with Rose
Friedman of the Friedman foundation for
educational choice so that's sort of how
I got involved in that why is school
choice important well from an economic
point of view ultimately in the
marketplace people's outcomes are going
to
determined by the human capital that
they acquire an education there's other
things and if you're a seven feet tall
dunk a basketball and stuff but the
human capital you acquire through
education ultimately is what the
marketplace rewards now libertarians
like to think of themselves as
transcending the left and right and I
would think that this would be the ideal
issue because when I see the left and
right fighting about social inequality
racial inequality income inequality and
stuff that's all downstream effect of
what people's education czar and if you
know largely and if you have if you have
one school where kids graduating with a
bucket of human capital and another
school where he's getting a thing or
someone else is getting a thimbleful
their life prospects are set so all the
politics that are about to downstream
stuff that's that's rearranging deck
chairs and the Titanic this is this is
the the issue are you hopeful for school
choice or what what's the development
and school choice that excites you the
most well and some of our you know the
problem is G I am ambivalent about the
prospects right now some of the more
noteworthy successes are getting rolled
back DC the DC voucher program being a
prime example which is just
heartbreaking and which reason TV has
done a nice a nice story on on the other
hand in one form or another
maybe not under the name vouchers but
under under different you know with
different words the idea of giving
parents choice seems to be catching on
and we discussed earlier some program in
Oakland for example but I think that
different mutations on vouchers are
starting to emerge and they and it the
good thing is as they make success as
they have success say in Arizona and
they expand the tuition tax credit it's
harder and harder for politicians to
roll it back because it develops a
constituency yeah what are your
intellectual and ideological influences
and roots why why do you call yourself a
libertarian and what does that mean well
I'm basically a Yankee I was a Yankee
Republican
and which meant I truth is I don't see
so so what appealed to me is the idea of
social freedom government in New
Hampshire New Hampshire Republican
believes government pave the roads build
the post office stay off my porch so we
look at the Republican Party today
and I don't recognize it and all these
people who want to get involved in your
life and what you do with yourself and
that's that's not the Republican as I'm
I grew up with on the other hand the
Democrats are so anti market and statist
and against economic freedom and that I
can't go with them so I used to say you
know a libertarian or somebody who's a
left-wing Democrat on social issues and
a conservative Republican on fiscal the
Republicans are no longer Republicans on
fiscal so I don't know where that leaves
us I want to thank Patrick Byrne CEO of
overstock.com and a PhD philosopher who
really knows the world of things as well
as ideas for talking to reason TV today
I'm Nick Gillespie